Disney and Marvel surprise rerelease of
avengers endgame is upon us and it looks
as though the companies have a single
goal in mind rake in enough money to
make the superhero ensemble the
highest-grossing movie of all time
there's just one big blue problem
standing between endgame and that highly
sought-after top spot avatar na'vi say
that every person is born twice the
second time is when you earn your place
among the people directed by James
Cameron avatar earned a whopping two
point seven four nine billion dollars
worldwide when it launched in 2009 the
flick a sci-fi epic starring Sam
Worthington as a former Marine named
Jake who travels to Pandora and
befriends the Navi people went on to
score even more money at the box office
when 20th Century Fox decided to
re-release it in 2010 in its second
theatrical outing avatar surpassed
Cameron's disaster romance epic Titanic
to become the biggest film in history
based on global revenue avatar now
stands tall atop a pile of cash that
amounts to two point seven eight eight
billion dollars avengers endgame the
culmination of over ten years of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe brought to
life by sibling filmmakers Joe and
Anthony Russo quickly soared past the
two billion dollar benchmark at the box
office after its debut during its
initial theatrical release that
officially began on April 26th endgame
effortlessly beat out Titanic which took
home two point one eight seven billion
dollars worldwide to become the second
best grossing movie in cinematic history
are you serious yeah though end games
commercial success slowly tapered off
following its massive opening the film
currently posts a staggering 2.75 1
billion dollars in global revenue with
screenings still happening as of Monday
June 24th clearly avatar and Avengers
endgame are neck-and-neck
the latter needs roughly 37 million
dollars more in global profits to push
past the former and be crowned as the
highest earning movie ever but is that
possible can endgame really make 40
million dollars worldwide when Disney
and Marvel kick off the re-release on
Friday June 28 if we do this how do we
know it's gonna end
any differently than it did before it
seems tough but not impossible when Fox
put avatar back in theaters a year after
its original release showing off nine
minutes of never-before-seen footage
that cost more than $1,000,000 per
minute to produce the film took home
just over 33 million dollars globally
accounting for the rise in ticket prices
from an average seven dollars and 89
cents per ticket in 2010 to an average
$9 and one cent per ticket in 2019
according to box office mojo the avatar
re-release would have made about thirty
seven point seven million dollars had
have been rolled out this year there's
arguably a much bigger market for
Avengers endgame than there was for
avatar given the film's mass appeal and
diehard fan base that will certainly
factor into how much money the endgame
rerelease pulls in as its second round
of success is largely down to how many
people head out the theaters to see the
new version of the movie the extra
content included in the re-release of
Avengers endgame should draw viewers
back in even those who have already
watched the super-sized superhero movie
several times Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige clarified in an interview
with Screen Rant when news of the
re-release went public that the new
version of the movie isn't an alternate
or extended cut instead it features
extra footage that's tacked on to the
end of the three-hour film fans have
likely already seen before Feige told
Screen Rant it's not an extended cut but
there will be a version going into
theaters with a bit of a marketing push
with a few new things at the end of the
movie if you stay and watch the movie
after the credits there will be a
deleted scene a little tribute and a few
surprises
trust me
[Music]
yup it's assumed that the tribute Feige
spoke of is one dedicated to Marvel
Comics maestro Stanley who passed away
at the age of 95 in November 2018 the
mystery surrounding the deleted scene
and these surprises that await fans
after the credits roll still remains and
Marvel is probably banking on that
intrigue translating into ticket sales
normally curiosity kills the cat but in
this case it could be the key to
Avengers endgame shattering the biggest
movie record there is the Avengers
endgame rerelease is said to begin on
Friday June 28th it's unclear how long
the new version will stay in theaters
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]